This is an I-Heart podcast. Guaranteed Human. On the Look Back at it podcast. From 1979, that was a big moment for me. 84 was big to me. I'm Sam J. And I'm Alex English. Each episode, we pick a year, unpack what went down,
这是一个I-Heart播客。百分之百真人。在Look Back at it播客中。从1979年开始，那对我来说是一个重要的时刻。84年对我很重要。我是萨姆·J。我是亚历克斯·恩格斯。每一集，我们都会选择一个年份，剖析发生了什么，
and try to make sense of how we survived it. With our friends, fellow comedians, and favorite authors. Like Mark Lamont Hill on the 80s. 84 was a wild year. It was a wild year. I don't think there's a more important year for black people. Listen to look back at it on the Outer. My Heart Radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts.
并试图理解我们是如何度过那段时光的。和我们的朋友、喜剧演员同行以及最喜欢的作家一起。比如马克·拉蒙特·希尔谈论80年代。84年是疯狂的一年。那是疯狂的一年。我认为没有哪一年对黑人来说比这更重要。在iHeartRadio应用程序、Apple Podcasts或您获取播客的任何地方收听Look Back at it。
Hey, what's good, y'all? You're listening to Learn the Hardway with your favorite therapist and host, Kear Games. This space is about black men's experiences, having honest conversations that it's really not safe to have anywhere, but you're having them with a licensed professional who knows what he's doing. How many men carry a suit or armor. It signals to the world that you not to be played with. And just because you have the capability that does not mean that you need to, Listen to learn the hard way on the AHA radio app, Apple Podcast, or wherever you get your podcast.
嘿，大家好，最近怎么样？你正在收听由你最喜欢的治疗师兼主持人凯尔·盖恩斯主持的《艰难成长》。这个空间关乎黑人男性的经历，进行在任何地方都感觉不太安全进行的坦诚对话，但你是在和一个知道自己在做什么的执牌专业人士进行交流。有多少男人背负着盔甲。它向世界发出信号，表明你是不好惹的。仅仅因为你有这种能力，并不意味着你需要这样做。在iHeartRadio应用程序、Apple Podcasts或您获取播客的任何地方收听《艰难成长》。
In 2023, Bachelor star Clayton Eckerd was accused of fathering twins. But the pregnancy appeared to be a hoax. You doctored this particular test twice in so much, correct? I doctored the test ones. It took an army of internet detectives to uncover a disturbing pattern. Two more men who'd been through the same thing. Greg, a lesbian, Michael Mancini. My mind was blown.
2023年，《单身汉》明星克莱顿·埃克德被指控是双胞胎的父亲。但这场怀孕似乎是一场骗局。你很大程度上两次篡改了这个特定的测试，对吗？我篡改了一次测试。这需要一大批互联网侦探来揭露一个令人不安的模式。另外两个经历过同样事情的男士。格雷格，一个女同性恋者，迈克尔·曼奇尼。我的脑洞大开。
I'm Stephanie Young. This is Love Trapped. Laura, Scottsdale Police. As the season continues, Laura Owens finally faces consequences. Listen to Love Trapped podcast on the IHeart Radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. 2%. That's the number of people who take the stairs when there is also an escalator available. I'm Michael Easter. And on my podcast, 2%. I break down the science of mental toughness, fitness, and building resilience in our strange model.
我是斯蒂芬妮·杨。这是《深陷爱河》。劳拉，斯科茨代尔警察局。随着节目的继续，劳拉·欧文斯终于面对了后果。在iHeartRadio应用程序、Apple Podcasts或您获取播客的任何地方收听Love Trapped播客。2%。这是当有自动扶梯可用时，仍选择走楼梯的人的比例。我是迈克尔·伊斯特。在我的播客《2%》中，我剖析了坚韧、健身的科学，以及在我们这个奇怪的现代世界中建立复原力的科学。
and worry. Put yourself through some hardships and you will come out on the other side a happier, more fulfilled, healthier person. Listen to 2%. That's TWO percent on the IHeartRadio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. Hello everybody and welcome back to the psychology of your 20s, the podcast where we talk through some of the big life changes and transitions of our 20s and what they mean for our psychology. Hello everybody. Welcome back to the show. Welcome back to the podcast, new listeners, old listeners, wherever you are in the world.
和焦虑。经历一些苦难，你最终会成为一个更快乐、更有成就感、更健康的人。在iHeartRadio应用程序、Apple Podcasts或您获取播客的任何地方收听《2%》。即TWO percent。大家好，欢迎回到《20多岁的心理学》，这是一个探讨我们20多岁时的一些重大生活变化和转变及其对我们心理学意味着什么的播客。大家好。欢迎回到节目。欢迎回到播客，新听众，老听众，无论你身在世界何处。
I'm so excited for today's episode because today we are talking about the idea or the psychological construct of codependency and not just in romantic relationships but also in other fundamental interpersonal relationships, particularly our friendships and with our family. I think that codependency can show up in so many facets of our social lives. And although there is a healthy amount of dependency and very real reasons why that kind of turns into codependency, when it's taken to extremes, when it's uncontrollable, what can emerge are pretty, I would say, parasitic, symbiotic relationships that restrict our lives. It is a very nuanced idea and a very nuanced concept, and I get this topic requested of me
我为今天的节目感到非常兴奋，因为今天我们讨论的是相互依赖的想法或心理结构，不仅在浪漫关系中，而且在其他基础的人际关系中，特别是我们的友谊和家庭关系。我认为相互依赖可以体现在我们社交生活的许多方面。尽管存在适度的依赖，且这种依赖转化为相互依赖有着非常现实的原因，但当它走向极端、无法控制时，所产生的可以说是相当具寄生性、共生性的关系，会限制我们的生活。这是一个非常微妙的想法和概念，这个主题经常有人向我请求
all the time, all the time, so it must be bothering some of us out there. And I honestly don't know why I haven't done it sooner, because it is such a crucial and a valuable discussion that needs to be had in this decade of our lives. I also think another reason I was really cool to almost do an episode on this, and the reason I wanted to discuss the idea of codependency is because I think that its meaning has been incredibly skewed by misinterpretations on the internet in pop culture, across social media, and when we use the term codependency, it's often really casual and flippant. And from the research that I've done, I've just come to realize it's so much more than that. So hopefully we can set the meaning straight in this episode and kind of dive into all of the psychology that is the basis of this concept and this idea, especially how it can become visible and can become a problem in our friendships and in our relationships.
一直以来，一直都是这样，所以它一定困扰着我们当中的一些人。老实说，我不知道为什么我没有早点做这个节目，因为这是一个如此关键且有价值的讨论，在我们生活的这个十年里有必要进行。我也认为我真的很想做一期关于这个主题的节目的另一个原因，以及我想讨论相互依赖这个想法的原因，是因为我认为它的含义已经被互联网、流行文化、整个社交媒体上的曲解严重扭曲了，当我们使用“相互依赖”这个词时，往往非常随心所欲和轻率。根据我所做的研究，我才意识到远不止于此。所以希望我们能在本期节目中弄清它的含义，并深入探讨构成这个概念和想法基础的所有心理学知识，尤其是它是如何在我们的友谊和关系中显现并成为问题的。
So we're going to discuss, of course, the history behind the term codependency, how it actually found its beginnings in AA meetings, of all places, how it shows up in our lives, how it manifests in our relationships, I guess also some of the warning signs and some of the causes of this experience of codependency, you know, specifically to do with our upbringing and childhood attachment, but I also want to talk about healthy dependency, interdependency, and what it really means to rely on, to love and trust other people in a way that is sustainable and healthy in what that means for our lives. But if you're listening to this with a bit of fear, maybe that a relationship of yours is becoming
所以我们当然要讨论“相互依赖”这个术语背后的历史，它是如何在AA（匿名戒酒互助会）会议中找到最初起源的，它如何在我们的生活中表现出来，它如何在我们的关系中体现，我想还有一些警告信号和导致这种相互依赖体验的一些原因，（你知道，具体与我们的成长经历和童年依恋有关），但我还想谈谈健康的依赖、相互依赖，以及真正去依赖、去以一种可持续且健康的方式爱和信任他人意味着什么，这对我们的生活意味着什么。但是，如果你在听这个节目时带有一点恐惧，也许担心你的某段关系正在变成
codependent, not to worry, because I also really want to rehash some of the discussions that we've had before around boundaries and how to separate yourself and someone you may be codependent with and restore a healthy amount of reliance and support between you and another person. this topic is so relevant for our 20s. I feel like in this decade, we are filled with so many emotions and deep feelings and realizations, but also insecurities. And quite frankly, things that we need help with, things that we haven't yet figured out. And the intensity of close relationships that we have in this decade, be that platonic with our family or intimate, those relationships can be such a
相互依赖，不用担心，因为我也真的很想重新温习我们之前关于界限的讨论，以及如何将你自己与你可能与之相互依赖的人区分开来，并恢复你与他人之间健康的依赖和支持。这个主题对我们的20多岁非常重要。我觉得在这个十年里，我们充满了许多情绪、深层感受和顿悟，但也充满了不安全感。坦白说，还有我们需要帮助的事情，我们尚未弄清楚的事情。我们在在这个十年中拥有的亲密关系的强度，无论是与家人的柏拉图式关系还是亲密关系，这些关系都可以成为一种
soothing band-aid almost for so many of our worries and concerns. But often when we cling to people in times of uncertainty, it can create problems. You know, I've had partners and friends who have been an absolute lifeline for me in periods of crisis. I felt like I couldn't live without them. But I think it's important to know when that is stepping into an unhealthy terrain and could actually potentially undermine what is best for us. So a discussion around codependency and how it manifests in the relationships we have, I think is so crucial. And if you can relate, well, you're definitely in the right place, I guess, and in for a treat because there's so much fascinating stuff behind the scenes of what we typically see or think of codependency and so many things to, I guess,
几乎可以抚平我们许多忧虑和关切的创伤贴。但通常情况下，当我们在不确定时期紧抓着人不放时，它会产生问题。你知道，我曾有过在危机时期绝对是我的救命稻草的伴侣和朋友。我觉得没有他们我活不下去。但我认为重要的是要知道什么时候这正在步入不健康的领域，并可能实际上潜在地破坏对我们最有利的东西。因此，围绕相互依赖及其在我们拥有的关系中如何体现的讨论，我认为至关重要。如果你能感同身受，嗯，那你绝对来对地方了，我想，你会有福了，因为在我们通常看到的或认为的相互依赖背后，有那么多迷人的东西，有那么多事情，我想，
discuss and explore. So get ready, strap in. I am so excited for this. deep dive and the discussion and all that is to come. 2%. That is the number of people who take the stairs when there is also an escalator available. I'm Michael Easter, and on my podcast, 2%. I break down the science of mental toughness, fitness, and building resilience in our strange modern world. I'll be speaking with writers, researchers, and other health and fitness experts, and more to look past the impractical and way too complete. Plex pseudoscience that dominates the wellness industry.
讨论和探索。所以准备好，系好安全带。我太兴奋了。深入探讨、讨论以及即将到来的一切。《2%》。这是当有自动扶梯可用时，仍选择走楼梯的人的比例。我是迈克尔·伊斯特，在我的播客《2%》中。我剖析了坚韧、健身的科学，以及在我们这个奇怪的现代世界中建立复原力的科学。我将与作家、研究人员和其他健康与健身专家等进行对话，以超越那些不切实际且过于复杂的伪科学，这些伪科学主导着健康产业。
We really believe that seed oils were inherently inflammatory. We got it wrong. Many of the problems that we are freaked out about in the world are the result of stress. Put yourself through some hardships and you will come out on the other side a happier, more fulfilled, healthier person. Listen to 2%. That's T-W-O-Persent on the I-Hart Radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcast. Do you remember when Diana Ross double-tap Little Kim's boobs at the VMAs? Or when Kanye said that George Bush didn't like black people.
我们真的相信种子油本质上会引起发炎。我们弄错了。我们在世界上惊慌失措的许多问题都是压力的结果。经历一些苦难，你最终会成为一个更快乐、更有成就感、更健康的人。在iHeartRadio应用程序、Apple Podcasts或您获取播客的任何地方收听《2%》。即T-W-O-Percent。还记得戴安娜·罗斯在VMA上双击小金（Lil' Kim）的胸部吗？或者坎耶说乔治·布什不喜欢黑人。
I know what you're thinking. What the hell does George Bush got to do with Little Kim? Well, you can find out on the Look Back at it podcast. I'm Sam Jek. And I'm Alex English. Each episode, we pick a here, unpack what went down, and try to make sense of how we survived it. Including a recent episode with Mark Lamont Hill, waxing all about crack in the 80s. To be clear, 84 is big to me, not just.
我知道你在想什么。乔治·布什跟小金（Lil' Kim）到底有什么关系？好吧，你可以在《Look Back at It》播客中找到答案。我是萨姆·杰克。我是亚历克斯·恩格斯。每一集，我们都会选择一个年份，剖析发生了什么，并试图理解我们是如何度过那段时光的。包括最近一期邀请马克·拉蒙特·希尔（Mark Lamont Hill）的节目，畅谈80年代的快克毒品。需要明确的是，84年对我很重要，不仅仅是因为。
just because of crack. I'm down to talk about crack on day, but just so y'all know. I mean, at this point, Mark, this is the second episode where we've discussed crack. So I'm starting to see that there's a through line. We also have AIDS on the table right now. Thank you finishing that sentence. Yes. I don't think there's a more important year for black people.
不仅仅是因为快克。我很乐意在白天谈论快克，但只是为了让你们知道。我的意思是，马克，这是我们讨论快克的第二集。所以我开始看到一条主线了。我们现在还把艾滋病摆在桌面上。谢谢你完成那句话。是的。我认为没有哪一年对黑人来说比这更重要了。
Really? Yeah. For me, it's one of the most important years for black people in American history. Listen to look back at it on the IHeart Radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get Your podcasts. Welcome to my new podcast, Learn the Hard Way with me, your host, and your favorite therapist, Kear Games. And in recognition of Mental Health Awareness Month, I'm bringing over a decade of my own
真的吗？是的。对我来说，这是美国历史上对黑人最重要的年份之一。在iHeartRadio应用程序、Apple Podcasts或您获取播客的任何地方收听《Look Back at It》。欢迎来到我的新播客《艰难成长》，我是主持人，也是你最喜欢的治疗师凯尔·盖恩斯。为了表彰心理健康意识月，我将带来我超过十年的
experience in the mental health field and conversations with so many incredible guests. I'm talking, Tript Fantine, Ryan Clark. Sometimes when we're in the pursuit of the thing, we get so wrapped up in the chase that we don't realize that we are in possession of the thing. And we're still chasing it. And we don't know when we've done enough. because people scoreboard watch. Life becomes about wins and losses. Steve Burns, Dustin Ross, because you find it important to be a good person while you hear on earth?
我在心理健康领域的经验，以及与众多不可思议的嘉宾的对话。我说的是特里普·凡廷、瑞安·克拉克。有时，当我们追求某样东西时，我们太陷入追逐之中，以至于没有意识到我们已经拥有了这样东西。而我们还在追逐它。我们不知道什么时候才算够。因为人们在看记分牌。生活变成了关于输赢。史蒂夫·伯恩斯，达斯汀·罗斯，因为你觉得在世期间做一个好人很重要吗？
Are you a good person because you're afraid? Because that's two different intentions, bro. Absolutely. And that's two different levels of trust. I want you to just really be a good person. Join me, Kear Gaines, is we have real conversations about healing, growth, fatherhood, pressure, and purpose on my new podcast, Learn the Hard Way. Open your free iHeartRadio app. Search Learn the Hardway. way and listen now. In 2023, former bachelor star Clayton Eckerd found himself at the center of a paternity scandal. The family court hearings that followed revealed glaring inconsistencies in her story.
你做一个好人是因为你害怕吗？因为那是两种不同的动机，兄弟。绝对是。那是两个不同层面的信任。我希望你能真正做一个好人。加入我，凯尔·盖恩斯，我们在我的新播客《艰难成长》中就治愈、成长、父亲身份、压力和目标进行真正的对话。打开你免费的iHeartRadio应用程序。搜索《Learn the Hard Way》并立即收听。2023年，前《单身汉》明星克莱顿·埃克德发现自己处于 paternity丑闻的中心。随后的家事法庭听证会揭露了她故事中显而易见的不一致之处。
This began a years-long court battle to prove the truth. You doctored this particular test twice in so much. I doctored the test once. It took an army of internet detectives to crack the case. I wanted people to be able to see what their tax dollars were being used for. sunlight's the greatest disinfected. They would uncover a disturbing pattern. Two more men who'd been through the same thing.
这拉开了历时多年的法庭之战以证明真相的序幕。你很大程度上两次篡改了这个特定的测试。我篡改了一次测试。这需要一大批互联网侦探来破解这个案件。我希望人们能够看到他们的纳税被用在了哪里。阳光是最好的消毒剂。他们会揭露一个令人不安的模式。另外两个经历过同样事情的男士。
Greg, the lesbian, Michael Marantini. My mind was blown. I'm Stephanie Young. This is Love Trap. Laura, Scottsdale Police. As the season continues, Laura Owens finally faces consequences. Ladies and gentlemen, breaking news at Maricopa County as Laura Owens has been indicted on fraud charges.
格雷格，那个女同性恋者，迈克尔·马兰蒂尼。我的脑洞大开。我是斯蒂芬妮·杨。这是《深陷爱河》。劳拉，斯科茨代尔警察局。随着节目的继续，劳拉·欧文斯终于面对了后果。女士们先生们，马里科帕县传来突发新闻，劳拉·欧文斯已被起诉欺诈罪。
This isn't over until Justice is served in Arizona. Listen to Love Trapped podcast on the Iheart radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. Like we always do, let's start this discussion, this exploration, by getting our basics down pat. What is codependency and what is the psychological basis, I guess, behind its existence and presentation in our lives? So essentially codependency is an unhealthy, dysfunctional relationship that is unbalanced, whereby
在亚利桑那州伸张正义之前，这一切都不会结束。在iHeartRadio应用程序、Apple Podcasts或您获取播客的任何地方收听《Love Trapped》播客。像往常一样，让我们通过弄清基础知识来开始这次讨论、这次探索。什么是相互依赖？我想，在其存在以及在我们生活中表现背后的心理基础是什么？所以本质上，相互依赖是一种不健康、功能失调且失去平衡的关系，其中
one person has assumed the role of the giver or the provider, there's someone who is willing to give and sacrifice everything for another person, whereas the other individual in this relationship is the taker. I think the first major element of this kind of relationship is that it is unhealthy. I think when we typically think about codependency as a society, as a community of people who have access to the internet and whatnot, we tend to imagine people who spend a lot of time together or who are really inseparable. You know, you may have a best friend who you see every day and you do everything with and you talk for hours and you can't imagine your life without. That isn't inherently unhealthy or codependent if both people are equally reliant. on each other or the relationship is what we would call mutually beneficial. You know, there is a
一个人承担了给予者或提供者的角色，总有人愿意为另一个人付出和牺牲一切，而这段关系中的另一个人则是索取者。我认为这种关系的主要第一个要素是不健康的。我认为当我们作为一个社会、作为一个能够上网等等的人群，通常想到相互依赖时，我们往往会想象那些花很多时间在一起或真正形影不离的人。你知道，你可能有一个每天都能见到、一起做所有事情、聊上几个小时、没有对方就无法想象生活的最好朋友。如果两个人对彼此的依赖程度相当，或者这段关系是我们所说的好处互惠的，这本身并不是不健康的或相互依赖的。你知道，有一个
balanced level of support and compassion from both parties. It becomes unhealthy and it becomes codependent when the balancing act is distributed or disturbed and it shifts in one person's favor. You know, it's no longer even. And this is really important when we consider the second element of codependency, which is that all the relationships that are codependent are seen as one-sided, you know, one person being the giver, one person being the taker. That doesn't mean that both parties don't actually get something from the arrangement, because the relationship that they have struck may mean that each is equally as dependent for different reasons.
双方支持和同情的水平均衡。当这种平衡行为被分配或扰乱并向一个人的利益倾斜时，它就变得不健康并且相互依赖了。你知道，它不再是均等的了。当我们考虑相互依赖的第二个要素时，这一点非常重要，那就是所有相互依赖的关系都被视为单方面的，（你知道，一个人是给予者，一个人是索取者）。这并不意味着双方实际上都没有从这种安排中得到任何东西，因为他们建立的关系可能意味着每个人出于不同的原因同样依赖对方。
I don't think this is to make a generalization about every codependent relationship, you I think when we talk about abusive relationships or abuse, we are moving away from simply, you know, codependency. And sometimes they come hand in hand, especially when we consider emotional abuse. But I think most people who we would consider as codependent, the nature of their codependency rests on that truth, that both parties are receiving something, regardless of whether they recognize that consciously. For example, in any codependent situation, we have that giver, we have that taker,
我认为这不是为了对所有相互依赖的关系一概而论，我认为当我们谈论虐待关系或虐待时，我们正在摆脱单纯的相互依赖。有时它们携手并进，尤其是当我们考虑情感虐待时。但我认为大多数我们认为是相互依赖的人，他们相互依赖的性质取决于这样一个事实：双方都得到了某些东西，不管他们是否有意识地意识到这一点。例如，在任何相互依赖的情况下，我们都有那个给予者，我们有那个索取者，
and each person has taken up one of those roles. That's essentially the equation of any codependent relationship. And although I think we may take pity on the giver because they're being really self-sacrificing, maybe they're unable to set boundaries or they're exhausted by their counterparts, needs to take from them or be reliant on them, they may get some satisfaction from providing this one-sided support to the taker, or they may feel responsible for their partner or their parents or
每个人都扮演了其中一个角色。这基本上就是任何共生关系的方程式。虽然我们可能会对付出者感到同情，因为他们真的在自我牺牲，也许他们无法设定界限，或者他们对伴侣需要从他们那里索取或依赖他们感到精疲力竭，但他们可能会从向索取者提供这种单方面的支持中获得一些满足感，或者他们可能会觉得对他们的伴侣、父母或
their friends and all that comes with that, their thoughts, their feelings and their actions. And in contrast, you know, the taker receives essentially unconditional love and support, you know, patience, money, forgiveness, whatever they need and they are willing to accept that. I think the term codependent, like I said, is often lobbied at people to describe them as kind of needy or really clingy.
朋友以及随之而来的一切负有责任，包括他们的想法、感受和行为。相比之下，你知道，索取者基本上接受无条件的爱与支持，你知道，耐心、金钱、宽容，无论他们需要什么，并且他们愿意接受这一点。我认为共生这个词，就像我说的，经常被用来形容人，把他们描述为有点需求过盛或非常粘人。
But it is so much more than that, and it's often encouraged in some ways by the giver and also the taker as well, I guess, because they share in the responsibility and need for each other. I saw it described really well
但它远不止于此，而且在某种程度上，付出者以及索取者也经常鼓励这种关系，我想，因为他们分担了责任和彼此的需求。我看到一篇文章对它进行了很好的描述
by this person called Dr. Legg in medical news today. And what they said essentially was that a codependent relationship occurs when one person needs the other who in turn needs to be needed. Like I said before, codependency, it's not just reserved for romantic relationships, as we may assume. It can really take place in any relationship which becomes unbalanced friendships, work relationships, family relationships with our parents. with our siblings, with our aunts and uncles, anyone that you have some kind of social interaction with. I often think about the people who message me
由《今日医学新闻》的一位名叫莱格博士的人提出的。他们的基本观点是，当一个人需要另一个人，而另一个人反过来又需要被需要时，共生关系就产生了。就像我之前说的，共生不仅仅局限于我们可能认为的浪漫关系。它确实可以发生在任何变得失衡的关系中，比如友谊、工作关系、与父母的家庭关系、与兄弟姐妹的关系、与叔叔阿姨的关系，以及任何与你有某种社交互动的人。我经常想起那些给我发信息的人
or tell me about friends of theirs who are absolutely reliant on them for all emotional support and they're constantly sacrificing their time and their energy to almost tend to this person. Whereas when they have problems or issues, that friend is never there for them. They're never willing to make those sacrifices.
或者向我讲述他们的朋友如何绝对依赖他们来获得所有情感支持，而他们却不断牺牲自己的时间和精力来几乎照顾这个人。然而，当他们遇到问题时，那个朋友却从不在他们身边。他们从不愿做出那些牺牲。
Their friend is completely dependent on them, whilst the other person just has to bear that and either can't do something or doesn't feel right about asking for that reciprocation. Withdrawing from that type of person, someone who is codependent on you, can be really, really difficult. And we're going to talk about that later, but interestingly, Before we jump into that, I think some of the history is quite fascinating. You know, the term codependent or codependency, it actually came out of research on the relationships between people who were suffering from addiction and the people that were close to them in their lives. That's where the term first appeared, amongst researchers who were studying people with addiction,
他们的朋友完全依赖他们，而另一个人只能默默承受，要么无能为力，要么觉得要求这种回报是不对的。从这种类型的人身边抽身——也就是对你产生共生依赖的人——可能会非常非常困难。我们稍后会讨论这一点，但有趣的是，在我们深入探讨之前，我认为其中的一些历史非常迷人。你知道，共生或共生关系这个词，实际上源于对受瘾症困扰的人以及他们生活中亲近之人的关系的研究。这个词就是这样首次出现的，在研究瘾症患者的研究人员当中，
and they used it to describe the almost lopsided or, you know, you know, one-sided enabling relationships between someone who was struggling, perhaps with alcohol abuse or substance abuse, and the people, you know, normally family and partners, who feel that they have to give in to that person's struggles and they have to help them. Then it kind of moved its way into AA, Alcoholics Anonymous Meetings, and then it kind of became a common term through that as it became more accessible to people. and I guess now it's been embraced by pop culture and pop, you know, and psychobabble to describe something that I think it really wasn't intended to represent. You know, essentially it was used to describe enabling relationships, you know, where one person is enabling another person's dependence on them or their dependence on something like drugs or alcohol.
他们用它来描述一个苦于酒精滥用或药物滥用的人与那些感到不得不向这个人的挣扎妥协并必须帮助他们的其他人（通常是家人和伴侣）之间，那种几乎是不平衡的、或者说单方面的助长关系。然后它进入了匿名戒酒互助会的会议，并通过这种方式变得更加为人所知，成为一个常用词，因为人们更容易接触到它。我想现在它已经被流行文化和心理学黑话所接受，用来描述一些我认为它原本并不打算代表的东西。本质上，它被用来描述助长关系，即一个人助长另一个人对他们的依赖，或者对药物或酒精等事物的依赖。
This actually really surprised me when I learned this because I think, like, like most people, I had a very naive, I would say, understanding of what it was. I used it very casually, but it is a lot more severe and intricate than that. So now that we kind of know some of the history and what I would call the basic elements of a codependent relationship, you know, that they're maladaptive, they're one-sided, they're unhealthy, I really want to provide a bit of an overview, I guess, of some of the warning signs in our own relationships. And those of people close to us as well, some of the things to look out for. I'm going to quickly state that although codependency is not something that you can be
当我了解到这一点时，其实感到非常震惊，因为我认为，就像大多数人一样，我对它是什么有着非常天真的理解。我曾很随意地使用它，但它比那要严重和复杂得多。所以，既然我们了解了它的一些历史以及我所说的共生关系的基本要素，即它们是适应不良的、单方面的、不健康的，我真的很想对我们自己关系中的一些危险信号做一个概述。还有我们身边之人的关系，一些需要注意的事情。我要快速说明的是，虽然共生不是那种你可以
diagnosed with per se, if you see some part of yourself or your own experience in what I'm describing, what I'm going to talk about, there is a lot of professional help out there for you and there are people that you can talk to, you know, you're not going to get a diagnosis or the person that you're speaking about isn't going to get a diagnosis. I think dependent personality disorder is probably the closest thing that we can get to and that's essentially describing pervasive, you know, psychological dependence on other people in which someone is unable to be independent and unable to meet their own emotional needs or make decisions and needs to receive constant approval from others. And I guess that is, it's unlike codependency in that it doesn't
被诊断出的病症，但如果你在我所描述、我将要谈论的内容中看到了自己或自己经历的一部分，外面其实有很多专业人士可以为你提供帮助，也有你可以倾诉的人，你知道，你不会得到一个诊断，你所谈论的人也不会得到一个诊断。我认为依赖型人格障碍可能是我们能找到的最接近的东西，这基本上是指对他人普遍存在的心理依赖，在这种状态下，一个人无法独立，无法满足自己的情感需求或做决定，并且需要不断获得他人的认可。我想，这与共生关系的不同之处在于，它并不
involve reliance on just one person. But I think that like the general psychological community, you know, the DSM, it hasn't really caught up to the fact that dependent personality disorder and codependency are actually quite hand in hand. And we speak a lot about codependency in terms of addiction, but there still isn't that recognition that this is something that is, can really affect someone's psychological and physical and emotional well-being. So let's talk about some of the, I guess, warning signs, some of the things to look out for. Firstly, in codependent relationships, there is going to be an imbalance of power. If you are finding that you are giving much more energy, time, love, patience to another person
仅仅依赖于某一个人。但我认为，就像整个心理学界一样，精神疾病诊断与统计手册（DSM）还没有真正跟上依赖型人格障碍和共生关系实际上息息相关这一事实。我们在讨论成瘾时经常谈到共生，但仍然没有承认这是一种真正会影响一个人心理、生理和情绪健康的事情。所以让我们来谈谈一些危险信号，以及一些需要注意的事项。首先，在共生关系中，会出现权力失衡。如果你发现自己正在付出更多的精力、时间、爱、耐心给另一个人，
who is really only using you for their own needs, that's probably the biggest indicator. So according to this clinical psychologist, I think their name was cododer Derek or something like that, we may feel when we're in this situation, if we are the giver in this situation, like we have to save the person from themselves. And we feel responsible for their emotional state and their well-being.
而对方其实只是在为了自己的需求而利用你，这可能就是最大的迹象。所以根据这位临床心理学家的说法，我想他的名字叫科多德·德里克还是什么的，当我们处于这种情境中时，如果我们是其中的付出者，我们可能会觉得自己必须把这个人从他们自己手中拯救出来。我们觉得自己对他们的情绪状态和福祉负有责任。
You know, you take over their response. for themselves and you help them pick up the pieces. In that instance in which you feel responsible for someone else, they're not able to do it without you, they need you, and you're kind of stuck, you're in this situation where you're like, I'm so stressed, I've lost my independence. It's a probably, you know, a fairly big indicator. The relationship is moving towards codependence. another huge indicator, and I feel like this is quite obvious, but I just feel like I need to state it for the record, is complete emotional exhaustion, even physical exhaustion. And what that comes from is essentially having to be responsible for another person, a grown adult, to the point that caring for yourself is almost the second priority, which it never should be. You know, the analogy I always use is that when a plane is crashing, when a plane is going down,
你知道，你接管了他们对自己的责任，你帮他们收拾残局。在这种你觉得必须为别人负责任的情况下，他们离开你就无法做到，他们需要你，而你有点被困住了，你处于这样一种境况：天哪，我压力太大了，我失去了独立性。这可能是一个相当大的迹象，表明这段关系正朝着共生发展。另一个巨大的迹象，我觉得这很明显，但我就是觉得我需要为记录在案说明一下，那就是完全的情绪精疲力竭，甚至是体力上的精疲力竭。这基本上源于不得不对另一个人（一个成年人）负责，以至于照顾自己几乎成了第二优先事项，而这绝不应该是这样的。你知道，我经常用的比喻是，当飞机失事时，当飞机下坠时，
you will never hear a flight attendant tell you to put the oxygen mask on someone else before yourself. And that goes for everyday relationships as well. You should always be helping yourself making sure that you are well before taking on that responsibility for others. And if you're feeling like your relationship with that person is taking time away from yourself, you know, that you don't want to answer their calls or their text messages because it's going to be disastrous if you feel intense anxiety when they message you or you stop doing what you're doing, you interrupt your plans to see them or to help them. That's a huge sign that your relationship is codependent, especially if they don't do the same for you.
你绝不会听到空乘人员叫你先把氧气面罩戴在别人脸上，再戴在自己脸上。日常关系也是如此。在承担起照顾他人的责任之前，你应当始终先帮助自己，确保自己状态良好。如果你觉得你与那个人的关系剥夺了你的个人时间，你知道，你不想接听他们的电话或回他们的短信，因为那会是一场灾难，如果你在他们发信息给你时感到极度焦虑，或者你停下正在做的事、打断你的计划去见他们或帮助他们，这就是这段关系处于共生的巨大信号，特别是如果他们对你并非如此的话。
I think it's worth acknowledging that when we are in these situations, it can be incredibly difficult to establish boundaries or even feel that we can put ourselves first because we are so wrapped up in our responsibility and our sense of loyalty to this other person, especially if, you know, they're your romantic partner or if they're your mother or your father or your sibling or your best friend. And I did a whole episode on kind of how to move forward from this called, I think it's like about setting boundaries and sticking to them. And I think that's really relevant here. So if you are really struggling, go and listen to that around setting boundaries with someone if it is a really emotionally tumultuous situation.
我认为值得承认的是，当我们处于这些情境中时，建立界限甚至觉得自己可以把自我放在首位会变得极其困难，因为我们太深陷于对这个人的责任感和忠诚感中了，尤其是当，你知道，他们是你的浪漫伴侣，或者你的母亲、父亲、兄弟姐妹或最好朋友时。我曾做过一整期播客来讨论如何摆脱这种状态，好像是关于设定界限并坚持下去的。我认为这在当前非常贴切。所以如果你真的在苦苦挣扎，去听听那一期关于如何在情绪极其动荡的情况下与某人设定界限的节目吧。
But there is a few more signs that I guess I just want to go through really quickly and which I think are so worth bringing up here. A lot of the signs that we've talked about so far have been how the giver feels, you know, that you might feel like your life revolves around this person. You don't have your own space. You feel, you know, stuck. You feel guilty. You feel shame. But in terms of the taker, there are some people who are in codependent relationships who are taking from someone else who might have that realization of like, this actually isn't healthy for me and it isn't healthy for them. So these people, they may really struggle with being alone and also feeling alone. They blame the other person for all that is wrong in their life. They say things like I couldn't live without you.
不过还有一些其他的迹象，我想简单过一遍，并且我觉得非常值得在这里提出来。我们目前讨论过的很多迹象都是关于付出者的感受，你知道，你可能会觉得你的生活围绕着这个人转。你没有自己的空间。你感到，你知道，被困住了。你感到内疚。你感到羞耻。但就索取者而言，有些身处共生关系中、从别人那里索取的人，可能会产生这样一种认识：这对我其实并不健康，对他们也不健康。所以这些人可能会非常难以独处，也难以忍受孤独感。他们把生活中所有的错误都归咎于另一个人。他们会说诸如“没有你我活不下去”之类的话。
their behavior might actually escalate in severity when you do try to set boundaries or you do try and pull away, they may use guilt against you or maintain a pretty strong sense of victimhood, even sometimes placing you as the villain. And all of this is really manipulative. But it doesn't always come from a place that wants to be cruel or come from a place that wants to be manipulative. It can also just be that they actually don't have a strong support system. They don't trust other people. And, you know, the sad truth is that people will only treat you the way that you allow them. So this pattern of behavior may have developed over a long period of time in which
当你试图设定界限或试图抽身时，他们的行为实际上可能会变本加厉，他们可能会对你进行道德绑架，或者保持相当强烈的受害者心态，甚至有时把扮演恶人的是你。所有这些都极具操纵性。但这并不总是出于想要残忍或想要操纵的动机。也可能只是因为他们确实没有强有力的支持系统。他们不信任其他人。而且，你知道，悲惨的事实是，别人只会用你允许的方式对待你。所以这种行为模式可能是在很长一段时间内发展起来的，在此期间
boundaries have not been well established or they haven't been respected. And it's not to victim blame or blame anyone or assign any stigma to either member of this kind of relationship, you know, vulnerability and relationships, even addiction, as we were saying before, they're really complex and they're really sensitive things. So if you're relating to any of this, either in a relationship with your partner or your friend, whoever, please don't blame yourself for this kind of relationship. I think we are all just trying our best with. what we have, but I think that it is really important to understand and be aware of what this
界限没有被很好地建立，或者没有被尊重。这并不是为了责怪受害者，也不是为了责怪任何人，或者给这种关系的任何一方贴上耻辱的标签，你知道，亲密关系中的脆弱性，甚至是瘾症，就像我们之前说的，它们真的是非常复杂且敏感的事情。所以，如果你与这些内容产生了共鸣，无论是在与伴侣还是朋友的关系中，无论如何，请不要为这种关系责怪自己。我认为我们大家都在用自己仅有的东西做到最好，但我认为理解并意识到这意味着什么确实非常重要。
means for us. And I think many of the signs are also what we would call the consequences of codependency. Often, if you were a clinical psychologist and someone came to you and said, my partner is so reliant on me, any time anything goes wrong, they need me to be there for them. I support them financially. other friends, but when I need support, they push me away. They're going to look at you and say, oh, that's codependent. You know, there's a lack of separation. There's a lack of individuality of healthy coping mechanisms or independence. And like I just mentioned, it may even result in the giver, often giving up money or resources for the other person. And there is, of course, that element of control, which we may associate with the taker, but actually, I,
对我们来说。而且我认为许多迹象也是我们所说的共生带来的后果。通常情况下，如果你是一名临床心理学家，有人来找你并说，我的伴侣太依赖我了，每当有任何事情出错，他们就需要我在他们身边。我在经济上支持他们。我有其他朋友，但当我需要支持时，他们却把我推开。他们会看着你说，哦，那是共生。你知道，缺乏分离感。缺乏个性、健康的应对机制或独立性。正如我刚才所提到的，这甚至可能导致付出者为对方放弃金钱或资源。当然，还有那种控制的成分，我们可能会将其与索取者联系起来，但实际上，我，
the party in this relationship can promote this to the point where it becomes unnatural and unhealthy. So why do these relationships happen? They sound quite unnatural, I would say. I think it's rare to see a full-blown codependent relationship in everyday life. They definitely still exist. So why is it that some people find themselves in such a toxic cycle? Well, as the origins of, you know, the term codependency suggests a huge risk factor or contributor is the presence of addiction in one or even both members. There was a study conducted in 2014 and it found that people who were surveyed who had a family member or a personal history of addiction, particularly with alcohol, they were more likely to report that they had been in a codependent relationship or that they had been
这段关系中的一方可以助长这种倾向，直到它变得不自然和不健康。那么，为什么会发生这些关系呢？听起来很不自然，我想说。我认为在日常生活中很少能看到完全彻底的共生关系。它们确实仍然存在。那么，为什么有些人会发现自己陷入如此有毒的循环中呢？正如“共生”这个词的起源所表明的那样，一个巨大的风险因素或促成因素是一方甚至双方存在成瘾问题。2014年进行的一项研究发现，接受调查的人如果有家庭成员或个人成瘾史，特别是酒精成瘾，他们更有可能报告自己曾处于共生关系中，或者他们曾对
codependent on someone else. And this study also examined whether men or women were more susceptible to codependency. And interestingly, these relationships were just as common within men and women, within both genders. That kind of surprised me, I will say, because I think that women are often very much stereotyped as being more nurturing and natural caregivers and really bad at setting boundaries, whatever you want to say. But I think that in these scenarios, really in these situations, everyone is just as susceptible
其他人产生共生依赖。这项研究还调查了男性还是女性更容易产生共生倾向。有趣的是，这种关系在男性和女性中、在两个性别中同样普遍。我必须说，这有点让我吃惊，因为我认为人们通常对女性有很强的刻板印象，认为她们更有养育能力、天生是照顾者、不擅长设定界限，无论你想怎么说。但我认为在这些情境中，确实在这些情况下，每个人都同样容易受到影响
as the next, regardless of gender. The factors that determine these kinds of relationships have a lot more to do with things like your childhood. You know, having a history of abuse or abandonment, that's a huge predisposing risk factor because often that means that that person, whoever it may be, has not been taught what a healthy, mutually beneficial relationship looks like. Remember how we learn to treat people and be treated is very much modelled on how our parents or our early caregivers conducted their relationships or treated us. And people who have unfortunately experienced
与性别无关。决定这些关系的因素与你的童年等因素有很大关系。你知道，有虐待或被遗弃的历史，这是一个巨大的诱发风险因素，因为通常这意味着这个人，无论他是谁，都没有被教导过健康、互惠的关系是什么样子的。记住，我们如何学会对待他人以及如何被对待，在很大程度上是以我们的父母或早期照顾者如何处理他们的关系或对待我们为模范的。而不幸经历过
abuse or abandonment, they themselves become more at risk of finding themselves in a codependent relationship, either as the giver or the taker, depending on what they lacked or had experienced in childhood. Honestly, I think like many problems, like codependency, the root of this problem, the cause of this problem is our upbringing and our family or childhood environment, especially if they were dysfunctional or they didn't provide our core emotional needs. And generally speaking, our attachment style patterns, that were developed in early childhood are really going to influence whether or not we end up in
虐待或被遗弃的人，他们自己更有可能发现自己陷入共生关系中，无论作为付出者还是索取者，这取决于他们在童年时期缺乏什么或经历过什么。老实说，我认为就像许多问题一样，共生问题的根源，这个问题的起因是我们的成长经历以及我们的家庭或童年环境，特别是如果它们功能失调或者没有提供我们核心的情感需求。总的来说，我们在幼儿时期形成的依恋风格模式，确实会影响我们最终是否会陷入
this, you know, this kind of scenario. With all of that in mind, what I really want to discuss next is the distinction between codependence and a healthy level of dependency that we would expect to see in our relationships. I think I've spent the large majority of this first bit of this episode really kind of drilling into our minds, how terrible this can be. how maybe we shouldn't rely on someone or we don't want to be deemed as codependent or too close. Obviously, that is not true. So I really want to discuss that distinction between codependence and healthy dependence or interdependency before we kind of outline some strategies for disentangling or distancing ourselves from codependent relationships.
这种，你知道，这种情境。考虑到所有这些，接下来我真正想讨论的是共生与我们在关系中所期望的健康依赖水平之间的区别。我想我在这期节目的第一部分花了大半时间，深入探讨了这可以有多糟糕，我们为什么可能不应该依赖某人，或者我们为什么不想被视为共生或过于亲密。显然，事实并非如此。因此，在我概述一些用于摆脱或疏离共生关系的策略之前，我真的很想讨论共生与健康依赖或相互依存之间的区别。
2%. That is the number of people who take the stairs when there is also an escalator. available. I'm Michael Easter, and on my podcast, 2%. I break down the science of mental toughness, fitness, and building resilience in our strange modern world. I'll be speaking with writers, researchers, and other health and fitness experts, and more to look past the impractical and way too complex pseudoscience that dominates the wellness industry. We really believe that seed oils were inherently inflammatory. We got it wrong. Many of the problems that we are freaked doubt about in the world are the result of stress. Put yourself through some hardships and you will come out on the other side a happier, more fulfilled, healthier person. Listen to 2%. That's TWO percent on the IHeart
2%。这是当有自动扶梯可用时，仍然选择走楼梯的人的比例。我是迈克尔·伊斯特，在我的播客《2%》中，我剖析了我们这个奇怪的现代世界中关于心理韧性、健身和建立抗逆力的科学。我将与作家、研究人员以及其他健康和健身专家等进行对话，以看透主导健康产业的不切实际且过于复杂的伪科学。我们真的曾认为种子油本质上具有炎症性。我们搞错了。我们在世界上所恐慌的许多问题都是压力的结果。经历一些苦难，你就会在另一端成为一个更快乐、更充实、更健康的人。收听《2%》。那是“IHeart”上的数字 2 percent。
Radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. Do you remember when Diana Ross double-tapped Little Kim's boobs at the VMAs? Or when Kanye said that George Bush didn't like black people. I know what you're thinking, what the hell does George Bush got to do a little kill? Well, you can find out on the Look Back at it podcast. I'm Sam Jett. And I'm Alex English. Each episode, we pick it here, unpack what went down, and try to make sense of how we survived it. Including a recent episode with Mark Lamont Hill waxing all about crack in the 80s.
Radio app、Apple Podcasts，或在您获取播客的任何地方。你还记得 Diana Ross 在 VMA 上双击了 Little Kim 的胸部吗？或者当坎耶说乔治·布什不喜欢黑人时。我知道你在想什么，乔治·布什到底跟小基尔有什么关系？好吧，你可以在 Look Back at it 播客中找到答案。我是萨姆·杰特。我是亚历克斯·英格利斯。每一集，我们都会在这里挑选一个，剖析发生了什么，并试着理解我们是如何挺过这一切的。包括最近一集，马克·拉蒙特·希尔大谈 80 年代的快克。
To be clear, 84 is big to me, not just because of crack. I'm down to talk about crack on day, but just so you all know. I mean, at this point, Mark, this is the second episode where we've discussed crack. So I'm starting to see that there's a through line. We also have AIDS on the table right now. Thank you finishing that sentence. Yes. I don't think there's a more important year for black people.
坦白说，84年对我很重要，不仅仅是因为快克。我随时都可以聊聊快克，不过为了让大家知道我的意思。我是说，马克，这是我们第二集讨论快克了。所以我开始看出一条贯穿始终的主线。我们现在还把艾滋病摆上了台面。谢谢你把话说完。是的。我认为对于黑人来说，没有比这更重要的一年了。
Really? Yeah. For me, it's one of the most important years for black people in American history. Listen to look back at it on the Iheart radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. Welcome to my new podcast, Learn the Hardway with me, your host, and your favorite therapist, Kear Games. And in recognition of mental health awareness month, I'm bringing over a decade of my own experience in the mental health field
真的吗？是的。对我来说，这是美国历史上对黑人而言最重要的一年之一。在 iHeart Radio app、Apple Podcasts 或您收听播客的任何地方收听 Look Back at it。欢迎收听我的新播客《Learn the Hard Way》，我是主持人、你最喜欢的治疗师 Kier Games。为了庆祝心理健康意识月，我带来了我在心理健康领域十多年的经验，
and conversations with so many incredible guests. I'm talking. Tripp Fontaine, Ryan Clark. Sometimes when we're in the pursuit of the thing, we get so wrapped up in the chase that we don't realize that we are in possession of the thing. And we're still chasing it, and we don't know when we've done enough.
以及与众多不可思议的嘉宾的对话。我说的是。特里普·方丹，瑞安·克拉克。有时，在我们追求某样东西的时候，我们太沉迷于追逐，以至于没有意识到我们已经拥有了它。而我们还在继续追逐，我们甚至不知道什么时候才算做够了。
Because people scoreboard watch. Life becomes about wins and losses. Steve Burns, Dustin Ross. because you find it important to be a good person while you hear on earth? Or are you a good person because you're afraid? Because that's two different intentions, bro. Absolutely. And that's two different levels of trust.
因为人们总是在看记分牌。生活变成了一场关于输赢的游戏。史蒂夫·伯恩斯，达斯汀·罗斯。因为你觉得在这个地球上做一个好人很重要？还是你做一个好人只是因为你害怕？因为这是两种完全不同的动机，兄弟。绝对是。这也是两个不同层次的信任。
I want you to just really be a good person. Join me, Kear Gaines, is we have real conversations about healing, growth, fatherhood, pressure, and purpose on my new podcast, Learn the Hardway. Open your free iHeartRadio app. Search Learn the Hardway and listen now. In 2023, former Bachelor star Clayton Eckerd found himself, at the center of a paternity scandal.
我希望你真的只是出于本心地做一个好人。加入我的新播客《Learn the Hard Way》，和我——Kier Gaines 一起，就疗愈、成长、父亲身份、压力和目标展开真实的对话。打开你免费的 iHeartRadio app。搜索 Learn the Hard Way 并立即收听。2023年，前《单身汉》明星克莱顿·埃克德发现自己卷入了产子丑闻。
The family court hearings that followed revealed glaring inconsistencies in her story. This began a years-long court battle to prove the truth. You doctored this particular test twice in someone's, correct? I doctored the test once. It took an army of internet detectives
随后的家庭法庭听证会揭露了她说法中明显的前后矛盾。这就引发了一场历时多年的维权诉讼。你曾两次篡改这个特定的测试结果给某人看，对吗？我只篡改了一次测试。这需要动用一大批互联网侦探
to crack the case. I wanted people to be able to see what their tax dollars were being used for. Sunlight's the greatest disinfected. They would uncover a disturbing pattern. Two more men who'd been through the same thing. Gillespie and Michael Maranini. My mind was blown. I'm Stephanie Young.
来破获这个案件。我希望人们能够看到他们的纳税被用在了哪里。阳光是最好的消毒剂。他们会揭露一个令人不安的模式。另外两个经历过同样事情的男士。吉莱斯皮和迈克尔·马拉尼尼。我震惊了。我是斯蒂芬妮·杨。
This is Love Trap. Laura, Scottsdale Police. As the season continues, Laura Owens finally faces consequences. Ladies and gentlemen, breaking news at Americopa County as Laura Owens has been indicted on fraud charges. This isn't over until justice is served in Arizona. Listen to Love Trapped podcast on the IHeart Radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. A healthy amount of reliance on someone else for support, for encouragement, and love is absolutely normal. In fact, I think it would be more worrying to me if we were completely
这就是《Love Trap》。劳拉，斯科茨代尔警察局。随着节目的继续，劳拉·欧文斯终于要承担后果了。女士们先生们，马里科帕县传来突发新闻，劳拉·欧文斯已被指控犯有欺诈罪。在亚利桑那州伸张正义之前，这事还没完。在 iHeart Radio app、Apple Podcasts 或您获取播客的任何地方收听 Love Trapped 播客。为了寻求支持、鼓励和爱，对他人保持适度的依赖是绝对正常的。事实上，如果我们与他人完全
detached from others and could never rely on someone else to fulfill some aspect of our emotional needs. We're social beings. We are pack animals, a tribal species at our core. And what that means is that we crave and we need connections with others. We need trust between ourselves and other people to thrive. So where can we draw the line between dependence and its evil twin, you know, codependency? I think the key distinction can be summed up in one word. Mutual. Mutual love, mutual support, mutual respect, mutual energy, mutual time.
疏离，永远无法依靠别人来满足我们情感需求的某个方面，那对我来说反而更令人担忧。我们是社会性动物。我们的核心是群居动物，是部落物种。这意味着我们渴望并需要与他人建立联系。我们需要我们与他人之间存在信任才能蓬勃发展。那么，我们该如何在依赖与它的邪恶双胞胎——也就是共生之间划清界限呢？我认为关键的区别可以用一个词来概括。相互。相互的爱、相互的支持、相互的尊重、相互的能量、相互的时间。
Healthy dependence, it involves a mutual give and take. It's not one-sided. Both people are able to receive the support and the encouragement and the practical help that they need. And of course there are going to be times in which you're going to have to support, you know, the other person more. Are they going to have to support you more than you're supporting them? You know, if your parent or your sibling is really sick, it makes sense that you may be doing more of the emotional and physical later. for them at that time. That is nothing to shy away from. That is not the point of this episode. You know, life is very much defined by its uncertainty and its ups and downs. And it's okay if you
健康的依赖，它包含相互的付出与回报。它不是单方面的。双方都能够获得他们所需要的支持、鼓励和实际帮助。当然，有时你确实需要更多地支持对方。或者他们可能需要比你支持他们更多地支持你？你知道，如果你的父母或兄弟姐妹病得很重，那么你在当时承担更多的情感和体力照顾是合情合理的。这没什么好回避的。这也不是本集重点。你知道，生活在很大程度上是由其不确定性以及起起落落所定义的。如果你偶尔
need someone a little bit more at times. You know, if you're going through a bit of a crisis or something else is going on, that's healthy. It's okay for our relationships to kind of peak and troth and to sometimes need people more than they need you. But if that's happening all the time, that's a problem. I think having a healthy level of dependence on others, like I explained, you know, being able to have that give or take, depending on what the other person is going through, being able to call on the people in your life for support, it's actually really positive. I don't feel like I need to say that, but it does have a lot of proven clinical benefits for our well-being and our overall outlook on life. They contribute to our sense of
更需要某人，那是没问题的。你知道，如果你正在经历一些危机或发生了其他事情，那是健康的。我们的关系出现高潮和低谷，有时比他们需要你更需要别人，这是正常的。但如果这种情况一直发生，那就是个问题了。我认为，正如我所解释的，对他人保持健康的依赖水平——能够根据对方的经历进行付出或回报，能够向你生活中的人寻求支持——其实是非常积极的。我觉得我不需要说这一点，但它确实对我们的幸福感和整体生活态度有很多已被证实的临床益处。它们有助于增强我们的
reliance, our resourcefulness. We have a stronger sense of trust in our own abilities. We are better at expressing our needs and our emotions. And we have greater self-esteem when we're able to promote healthy independence and healthy dependence in our relationships. And that all sounds really positive because it is. It's healthy and it's something that we can pursue. But when it emerges as a problem is when you are unable to detach, you need something else for your support. You know, this person is everything to you, or you're giving someone else everything of you
依赖感、应变能力。我们对自己的能力有更强的信任感。我们更擅长表达自己的需求和情感。当我们在关系中能够促进健康的独立和健康的依赖时，我们会拥有更高的自尊。这听起来真的很积极，因为它确实如此。它是健康的，是我们能够追求的。但当它成为一个问题时，是因为你无法抽离，你需要其他东西来获得支持。你知道，这个人对你而言就是一切，或者你把自己的全部都给了别人，
beyond what could possibly be expected in any situation. And we have to remember here that co-dependence is maladaptive and it's harmful to both members of the relationship. I read an incredible article that explained this distinction really well and it explained the distinction between codependence and independence or interdependence more like it. as helping versus enabling. If you think that your relationship with someone has fallen into a giver and a taker situation,
超出了任何情况下可能有的预期。我们必须在这里记住，共生是适应不良的，对关系的双方都是有害的。我读过一篇非常棒的文章，很好地解释了这种区别，它解释了共生与独立（或者更准确地说是相互依赖）之间的区别，将其比作“帮助”与“纵容”。如果你认为你与某人的关系已经陷入了付出者和索取者的境地，
ask yourself whether your actions and your responses to them are helping them or enabling them. You know, if your friend keeps coming to you for money but never paying you back or showing any progress towards being financially independent, this may seem like you're helping them at the surface level. You know, you're helping them through a tough time, but it actually may be that you're enabling their dependency on you for assistance. I always try and frame my decisions around whether my actions are helping someone to become self-sufficient or whether I'm doing it for myself because I want to feel better. You know, or I'm helping them to the point that they, you know, they don't need to,
问问自己，你的行为以及你对他们的反应是在帮助他们还是在纵容他们。你知道，如果你的朋友不断找你借钱，却从不还钱，也没有表现出任何经济独立的进展，这在表面上看起来可能像是在帮他们。你知道，你是在帮他们度过难关，但实际上你可能是在纵容他们对你的经济援助的依赖。我总是试图将我的决定建立在以下基础上：我的行为是在帮助某人变得自给自足，还是我这么做只是为了让自己感觉更好。或者说，我在帮他们到这种程度——他们甚至不需要，
help themselves and they don't need to help me, right? Like they're just relying on me for something and they're not able to take responsibility for their problems. That's a really tricky situation to be in. And I don't think we need to apply that perspective to all of our relationships, but it is something to be cognizant of. Doesn't mean you need to say no or that you can't help someone out in a tricky situation, but when it starts to look like enabling behavior, it probably isn't helping either of you. Maybe you're listening to this and you're like, this is me. This is me. I'm in this situation. I'm really struggling and you've been able to identify yourself as being in a codependent situation, whether that is with a parent, with a romantic partner, with a friend, it really doesn't matter.
自己解决问题，也不需要帮助我，对吧？就像他们只是在某些事情上依赖我，却无法为自己的问题承担责任。处于这种境地真的很棘手。我不认为我们需要将这种观点应用到我们所有的关系中，但这是需要意识到的一点。这并不意味着你需要说“不”，或者你不能在棘手的情况下帮助别人，但当它开始看起来像纵容行为时，它可能对你们俩都没有帮助。也许你正在听这段话，心想：这就是我。这就是我。我就是这种状况。我真的很挣扎，而且你已经能够识别出自己正处于一种共生关系中，无论那是与父母、浪漫伴侣还是朋友，这其实并不重要。
So how do we move back to a healthy level of interdependency and dependence? And how do we restructure our relationship with that person so that it doesn't compromise our identity? It doesn't compromise our self-esteem or, you know, our entire lives, our welfare. Healing a relationship from codependency, it's going to take time because it's like separating out someone's addiction to you. you know, fighting against your addiction to them. All of that is exhausting. It's also neurologically very difficult because when we do become reliant on anything,
那么，我们该如何回到健康的相互依赖和依赖水平呢？我们又该如何重塑与那个人的关系，使其不损害我们的身份？不损害我们的自尊，或者说，不损害我们的整个生活和福祉？治愈一段共生关系需要时间，因为这就好比剥离某人对你的瘾。你知道，与你对他们的瘾作斗争。所有这些都是极其耗精力的。从神经学角度来看这也非常困难，因为当我们对任何事物产生依赖时，
be that a drug or a person in this situation, what happens to our brain is that our neurons and our synaptic pathways, they become wired towards wanting that person or whatever it is that we're addicted to. it's a process called long-term potentiation whereby the more that we activate a certain pathway, the stronger it becomes and the harder it is to break that pattern or consumption. And when those pathways are no longer activated, you know, when someone is having a problem
无论是药物还是这种情境下的人，我们大脑发生的情况是，我们的神经元和突触通路会变得倾向于渴望那个人，或者无论我们对什么上瘾。这是一个被称为“长期增强”的过程，通过这个过程，我们激活某个特定通路的次数越多，它就会变得越强，我们就越难打破这种模式或消耗。而当这些通路不再被激活时，你知道，当某人遇到问题
and they go, oh my gosh, I cannot call that person. Or when someone calls you with a problem and you go, oh my gosh, I can't help you because this is unhealthy, it's distressing. The first step I think I would always recommend is to get some outside help or an outside and objective perspective on the relationship in question and the problem that you're facing. It can be very difficult to be honest with ourselves when a situation is so emotionally charged and at times probably even tense or dangerous. So going to a trusted friend, a mentor, a mental health professional based on whatever. a resource you have, just someone who's separate from the situation, it's sometimes really important because it gives you a logical bird's eye view. So you can see clearly why this scenario is hurting
他们会想：哦天哪，我不能打电话给那个人。或者当有人带着问题打电话给你，而你说：哦天哪，我不能帮你，因为这很不健康，这让人感到痛苦。我想我总是会推荐的第一步是为所讨论的关系和您面临的问题寻求一些外部帮助或外部客观的视角。当情况充满情绪化、有时甚至紧张或危险时，要对自己诚实是非常困难的。因此，去找一个值得信赖的朋友、导师、心理健康专家，根据你有什么资源，找一个与这种情况无关的人，有时真的很重要，因为它能给你提供一个合乎逻辑的鸟瞰视角。这样你就能清楚地看到为什么这个剧本会伤害
you, why it's hurting the other person, why it's probably really good if you get some space. And, you know, they may also just have some really good advice and they may be able to provide some options to you that you haven't considered. The next, the next, next step that I think is important is to ground yourself in why you have acknowledged that this is maladaptive and unhealthy and find a way to make your thoughts and your feelings on the matter tangible. I think this applies to even situations beyond codependency. Any problem that you have, anything you're trying to solve, making a notes list or journaling to yourself about how you feel, why this is difficult, why you want to change. It's so much easy.
你，为什么它会伤害另一个人，为什么如果你能保持一些距离可能会更好。而且，你知道，他们可能也会有一些非常好的建议，并且能够为你提供一些你没有考虑过的选择。下一个，下一个，下一步，我认为很重要的一点是，要深入思考你为什么承认这是适应不良和不健康的，并找到一种方法，将你对此事的想法和感受具体化。我认为这甚至适用于共生关系之外的情况。你遇到的任何问题，你试图解决的任何事情，做个笔记列表，或者写日记记录你的感受、为什么这很困难、为什么你想改变。这样会容易得多。
easier to motivate yourself or to move through a difficult transition when you have some written reminder about why you need to do something, why you are making that change. This list might include things in this situation like I don't like how I'm feeling stuck. Or in this relationship, I'm not able to promote my independence or I'm not able to be independent. Or situations or statements about how the situation is making you feel. and why it needs to change. And that way, you can come back to it whenever you feel yourself slipping back into old pabets or old patterns.
当你有一些关于为什么要这么做、为什么要做出这种改变的文字提醒时，你就会更有动力去激励自己或度过艰难的转型期。这份清单可能包括这种情况下的内容，例如：我不喜欢这种卡住的感觉。或者在这段关系中，我无法促进我的独立，或者我无法做到独立。或者关于这种情况如何让你感觉的陈述，
I think the next really valuable step to take, and if you've listened to my boundaries episode, this may sound really familiar, it's to confront the person and to confront the problem and have an honest conversation. I know it's really scary. I've done it before. It is terrifying. but I think one of the worst feelings in the world is when someone makes a decision without consulting you or completely goes to you or shuts you out. Obviously that's necessary sometimes and there are people who are just really bad for our health and you can make that call based on your own personal appraisal
以及为什么它需要改变。通过这种方式，每当你觉得自己快要滑回旧习惯或旧模式时，你都可以重新阅读它。我认为下一个非常有价值的步骤，如果你听过我关于边界的那集，这听起来可能非常熟悉，那就是去面对这个人，面对问题，并进行一次坦诚的对话。我知道这真的很可怕。我以前做过。这太吓人了。但我认为世界上最糟糕的感觉之一就是有人在没有征求你意见的情况下做出决定，或者完全避开你，或者把你关在门外。显然这有时是必要的，有些人对我们的健康确实非常有害，你可以根据自己的个人评估做出这种决定
of the situation or the extent of the codependency but if the situation allows it I personally believe it's actually quite almost cruel, I think, to leave someone with no explanation or discussion. And you don't need to treat it as a two-way street or like the decision is up for debate. Just simply lay out the facts and your feelings and why you feel like you would both benefit from this, why you would like your situation to change, and leave it at that. Leave it at that. You don't need to answer questions. You don't need to justify anything.
了解具体情况或共生程度，但如果情况允许，我个人认为，把一个人留在没有任何解释或讨论的情况下，其实几乎是残忍的。你不需要把它当作双向街道，或者好像这个决定可以争论。只需简单地陈述事实、你的感受、为什么你觉得你们俩都会从中受益、为什么你希望你们的情况有所改变，然后就此打住。就此打住。你不需要回答问题。你不需要为主张任何事情辩护。
and that person may actually surprise you and say, you know, like, I've actually been feeling this way as well, and I want our relationship to be healthier, or, you know, I want this for us. But I think honesty is always the best policy in emotionally sensitive situations, whatever they may be. I think now comes the difficult part, which is sticking to your guns, respecting your own boundaries, learning to say no when that person pushes up against what you have decided to do. it's okay to fail a few times to find, you know, that separation hard or even painful. Like I said, you're neurologically and physically inclined to feel this way. But if as the giver you're still answering their calls at any time of the night,
而那个人实际上可能会让你感到惊讶，并说：“你知道吗，其实我也有这种感觉，我希望我们的关系更健康，”或者“你知道的，我希望我们能这样。”但我认为在情感敏感的情况下，诚实永远是上策，无论情况如何。我想现在是最困难的部分了，那就是坚持立场，尊重自己的界限，当那个人试图突破你决定好的底线时，学会说“不”。犯几次错、发现这种分离很困难甚至痛苦，是正常的。就像我说的，你在神经上和身体上都倾向于这样感受。但如果你作为付出者，仍然在夜里的任何时间接听他们的电话，
or as the taker, you're finding that your emotional state is based on how that person is treating you or the attention they're giving you and you cannot fight that urge, then the boundary I don't think has been fully set. or it hasn't been fully respected. So make some non-negotiables or some rules for yourself in these situations, and I mean rules, not things that you would like to do, but tangible decisions you're going to be accountable to yourself for. It might also help to have someone else who can kind of help you stay on track
或者作为索取者，你发现你的情绪状态取决于那个人如何对待你或他们给你的关注，而你无法抗拒这种冲动，那么我认为这个边界还没有完全建立。或者它没有被完全尊重。因此，在这些情况下为自己制定一些不可妥协的事项或规则，我指的是规则，而不是你希望做的事情，而是你将对自己负责的具体决定。这也可能会有所帮助，如果有其他人可以某种程度上帮助你保持正轨，
or who you can kind of answer to or update them on your progress and who can help you kind of question your decisions, not necessarily make you feel guilty, but make you appreciate the reasoning behind maybe why you're struggling to keep that boundary. After a slip-up, whatever it may be, it's also really crucial to reflect on how it's left you feeling. You know, did you let someone back into your life in the way that you didn't necessarily want? Or if you felt that you came back to someone you didn't want to be reliant on, don't suppress that feeling. Don't suppress that shame almost. Sit with it. Process it. Think about how you might change your future actions to avoid this situation.
或者你可以向他们汇报或更新你的进展，并且他们可以帮助你质疑你的决定——不一定是让你感到内疚，而是让你理解为什么你可能难以坚守这条边界背后的原因。在失误之后，无论那是什么，反思它给你留下了怎样的感受也至关重要。你知道，你是不是以一种你并不真正希望的方式让某人重新回到了你的生活？或者如果你觉得你又回到了某个你不想依赖的人身边，不要压抑这种感觉。不要压抑这种羞耻感。去体会它。去处理它。想想你可能会如何改变你未来的行为来避免这种情况。
Be future looking. Imagine where you would like to be. Be like, okay, last night I went over to this person's house and I helped them out, even though I know this is codependent, even though I really want some separation. And now I feel really bad. I feel really, really crap about myself. Instead of being like, oh my God, I don't want to feel that. That's really uncomfortable.
面向未来。想象一下你想去的地方。比如，“好吧，昨晚我去了那个人的家，我帮了他们，尽管我知道这是一种共生关系，尽管我真的很想保持一些距离。现在我感觉真的很糟糕。我对自己的感觉糟透了。”而不是说：“哦天哪，我不想有这种感觉。这真的让人很不舒服。”
Allow yourself to feel that way. and then look to the future. And I guess that applies for everything, not just breaking free of codependency. When we look towards the future, our progress is going to be more steady. Obviously, you can follow these steps, you can take my advice, do everything right,
允许自己去感受那种情绪，然后展望未来。我想这适用于所有事情，不仅仅是摆脱共生关系。当我们展望未来时，我们的进步会更加稳健。显然，你可以遵循这些步骤，你可以接受我的建议，把所有事情都做好，
but the thing is about any relationship is that it's always complicated, it's always nuanced, and you know what you're going through more than I ever could. So take it slow, be kind to yourself, and I really hope that this information has helped you. I feel like I've learnt so much from this discussion and this research,
但任何关系的问题在于它总是复杂的，总是充满细微差别的，而且你所经历的远比我所能理解的要多得多。所以慢慢来，对你自己好点，我真的希望这些信息能帮到你。我觉得从这次讨论和研究中我学到了很多，
especially about so many of the misconceptions around codependency and how we can distinguish it from healthy dependency and interdependency. It's just such a fascinating topic, especially for our 20s, where I feel like a lot of us have really intense relationships with people, whether that is, you know, really good friends or the people that we're dating. And it can really feel like it's just us too in this bubble. And one of us is really reliant on the other person and is taking so much and the other person can't leave. And it's just really emotionally volatile. So if you can relate, you deserve a lot of credit. I'm sure it's really difficult. But hopefully
特别是关于围绕共生的许多误解，以及我们如何将其与健康的依赖和相互依赖区分开来。这真是一个迷人的话题，特别是对于我们的 20 多岁来说，我觉得我们中的许多人与人有着非常强烈的情感关系，无论是很好的朋友还是我们正在约会的人。这种感觉真的就像这个气泡里只有我们俩。其中一个人非常依赖另一个人，索取了那么多，而另一个人又无法离开。这种关系在情感上真的很不稳定。所以如果你能感同身受，你应该获得很多赞赏。我确信这真的很困难。但希望
this episode gave you some sense of the future and some sense of what you can do. Thank you for listening today. I think that's all that we have time for. I'm really hopeful and, yeah, hoping that you enjoyed it. I really did as well. So if you did enjoy this episode, if you learned something, that's the most important. Please feel free to leave a five-star review on Apple Podcast, Spotify, wherever you are listening right now. If you want to follow us on Instagram, that's where I let my listeners decide what I record for the next week, so you can contribute to what you want to hear. And thank you so much for listening.
这一集为你提供了一些对未来的感知以及你可以做些什么。谢谢你今天的收听。我想我们今天的时间就到这里了。我真的充满希望，是的，希望你们喜欢。我也真的很喜欢。所以如果你喜欢这一集，如果你学到了东西，那才是最重要的。请随时在 Apple Podcast、Spotify 或你现在收听的任何地方留下五星好评。如果你想在 Instagram 上关注我们，那是我让听众决定我下周录制什么内容的地方，所以你可以为你想听的内容贡献力量。非常感谢大家的收听。
Thank you so much for tuning in. I feel very grateful that people want to hear what we're discussing and people are interested in these topics as much as I am and are willing to learn as much as I really like learning. So thank you so much for joining us for this journey and have an absolutely lovely week. On the Look Back at it podcast. From 1979, that was a big moment for me.
非常感谢大家的收听。我感到非常感激，大家愿意倾听我们的讨论，并且对这些话题像我一样感兴趣，愿意像我一样去学习。非常感谢大家陪伴我们踏上这段旅程，祝大家拥有一个非常愉快的星期一。在 Look Back at it 播客中。从 1979 年开始，这对我和而言是一个重大的时刻。
84's big to me. I'm Sam J. And I'm Alex English. Each episode, we pick a here, unpack what went down and try to make sense of how we survived it with our friends, fellow comedians, and favorite authors. Like Mark Lamont Hill on the 80s. Before it was a wild year.
对我和而言，84 年是个大年份。我是萨姆·J。我是亚历克斯·英格利斯。每一集，我们挑选一个年份，剖析发生了什么，并试图通过我们的朋友、喜剧演员同行和最喜欢的作家，来理解我们是如何挺过这一切的。就像马克·拉蒙特·希尔谈论 80 年代一样。在那之前，这是个疯狂的年份。
It was a wild year. I don't think there's a more important year for black people. Listen to look back at it on the IHeart Radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. Hey, what's good, y'all? You're listening to Learn the Hard Way with your favorite therapist and host's Kier Games. This space is about black men's experiences, having honest comments. conversations that it's really not safe to have anywhere, but you're having them with a licensed professional who knows what he's doing. How many men carry a suit or armor. It signals to the
这是个疯狂的年份。我认为没有比这更重要的一年了。在 iHeart Radio app、Apple Podcasts 或您获取播客的任何地方收听 Look Back at it。嘿，大家好，你们好吗？欢迎收听《Learn The Hard Way》，我是你们最喜欢的治疗师兼主持人 Kier Games。这个空间是关于黑人男性的经历，进行诚实的对话，
world that you not to be played with. And just because you have the capability that does not mean that you need to, listen to learn the hard way on the AHA radio app, Apple Podcast, or wherever you get your podcast. In 2023, Bachelor star Clayton Eckerd was accused of fathering twins. But the pregnancy appeared to be a hoax. this particular test twice in someone's, correct? I doctored the test ones. It took an army of internet detectives to uncover a disturbing pattern. Two more men who'd been through the same thing.
在其他地方可能真的不太安全，但你是在跟一位知道自己在做什么的专业持证人员交流。有多少男人穿着盔甲。它向世界发出信号，说明你不是好惹的。仅仅因为你有这种能力，并不意味着你需要这样做，在 AHA 广播应用、Apple Podcast 或你获取播客的任何地方收听《Learn the Hard Way》。2023 年，《单身汉》明星克莱顿·埃克德被指控是双胞胎的生父。但这次怀孕似乎是个骗局。你曾两次篡改这个特定的测试结果给某人看，对吗？我只篡改了一次测试。这需要动用一大批互联网侦探
Greg, a lesbian. Michael Mancini. My mind was blown. I'm Stephanie Young. This is Love Trapped. Laura, Scottsdale Police. As the season continues, Laura Owens finally faces consequences. Listen to Love Trapped podcast on the Iheart radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your
来破获这个案件。格雷格，莱斯利。迈克尔·曼奇尼。我震惊了。我是斯蒂芬妮·杨。这就是《Love Trapped》。劳拉，斯科茨代尔警察局。随着节目的继续，劳拉·欧文斯终于要承担后果了。在 iHeart Radio app、Apple Podcasts 或您获取播客的任何地方收听 Love Trapped 播客。2%。这是有自动扶梯可用时，依然选择走楼梯的人的比例。我是迈克尔·伊斯特。在我的播客《2%》中，
podcasts. 2%. That's the number of people who take the stairs when there is also an escalator available. I'm Michael Easter. And on my podcast, 2%. I break down the science of mental toughness, fitness, and building resilience in our strange modern world. Put yourself through some hardships, and you will come out on the other side a happier, more fulfilled, healthier person. Listen to 2%. That's TWO%.
我将剖析心理韧性、健身的科学，以及在我们这个奇怪的现代世界中建立复原力的科学。经历一些艰难困苦，你最终将以一个更快乐、更充实、更健康的姿态走出困境。收听《2%》。也就是 TWO%。
on the IHeart radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. This is an IHeart podcast. Guaranteed human. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
在 iHeart Radio app、Apple Podcasts 或您获取播客的任何地方。这是一个 iHeart 播客。保证由真人制作。本集暂无评论。点击转录文本中的任意句子即可留下评论。